all right kyle we are here we are
celebrating halloween kills i i i have
to ask you you broke your nose filming
this thing
let's just start there how did that
happen tell me that story well i was
working with a stunt coordinator to do
the fight scene with michael myers and
yeah let's just say while i was
rehearsing something flew back and hit
me in the face and i knew immediately
something was wrong but i didn't want to
tell anybody because i didn't want the
stunt double to take over my
job like a like a like a true performer
like a true star you want to do this
when you're looking at someone standing
there looking just like you dressed like
you waiting for their
turn i was like no i want to do this
myself so i i sort of kept it together
and then when i got back to la i found
out it was indeed broken oh my goodness
well it looks lovely i'm just saying
thank you it's been fixed since all
right the next thing i have to bring up
because i was
so nostalgic when i saw
the bangs on your character did this
help put you right back in to the to the
character for you it was definitely a
choice no doubt
um yeah you know i wanted to
bring lindsay back as an adult but you
know we had to have that throwback from
1978.
so yes i wanted the bangs and the plaid
the plaid jacket yeah and let's talk
about that so we're we're 40 years later
essentially reprising this role that you
you played as a little girl you know
what did you do to develop the character
differently now that she's grown and
obviously scarred and has these
different memories right well i spoke
with our director david gordon-green and
i just you know
really had to think about who is lindsay
now you know
obviously going through what she went
through as a child affects her her
entire life and where is she at in her
life you know she's still in hatton
field
and you know so i had to think about
what did she do for a living does she
have children i kind of kept it to
myself but i did go through all of that
process to bring my character back it is
nostalgia at its finest for me i grew up
on these movies i loved it so much now
tell me about reuniting with jamie lee
curtis was it was it spectacular for you
to feel like you guys haven't skipped a
beat well you know we've kept our
friendship over these years and we share
not only the bond of halloween but also
we're big supporters of children's
hospital los angeles so we've gotten
together over the years to raise money
for children's hospital
so you know and she's always been really
loving and supportive towards me so when
i showed up on set of course like always
she came right into my dressing room and
gave me a big hug and just like she did
today
and you know it's just amazing after all
these years to still have that bond that
we've always had michael myers walks on
set is it scary is he friendly are you
having conversations between takes well
you know when we're not working yes
we're sitting there we're talking but
the second that mask goes back on it's
scary no matter what
you know it's not scary and it wasn't
scary for me making this movie when i
was a little girl because i didn't
really grasp what we were doing but now
as an adult we're filming you know night
shoots 3 30 in the morning you're
looking over it's dark like this and to
see that figure
his body language alone is so
creepy and he's got the knife and it's
just like oh just freaks me out every
time all right be honest i want to play
a little game with you okay who's more
vicious michael myers or the housewives
in a spat
the housewives okay
i want to talk about that because
michael myers doesn't do spats he
doesn't do he doesn't doesn't do the
small spats he goes goes right for the
kill
um all right i want to talk about your
impressions for a second i want to talk
about your impressions of some of the
housewives if you will okay michael
myers walks in
on the said housewife give me your best
impression
if you will if you feel comfortable
lisa arena oh my god harry hamlin
michael myers is in the house harry
oh my god
i feel like this dead on it's so good
okay okay okay michael myers walks in on
erica jane oh my god
it's michael myers
i can't believe this that's okay we're
good we're good
all right last one michael myers walks
in
kathy hilton wait
is that
kyle
he looks familiar
who's that
who is that
why do i know that guy
these are so good you should
i literally want to see a 15-minute
stand-up routine of you doing reactions
with scary movies for all your co-stars
i love it let's talk about housewives
just for a second the reunion right it's
four parts tell me anything you can
about it what can you tease us with well
the reunions are never fun nobody wants
to be there everyone dreads it you know
and andy is usually like the
psychologist of the group okay but
this time it was more like
it was like a trial i mean there was a
lot of stuff going on you know when andy
was really digging in deep i was like my
god you know are you a lawyer too
lawyer psychologist you know also
stirring up stuff yeah
you